no disintegrations hold on to your
lightsabers friends because more news
has surfaced about season two of the
mandalorian including the appearance of
Boba Fett oMG so we're gonna break all
of that down and more right now on the
ketchup
after a certified fresh' first season
the anticipation and buzz surrounding
season 2 the Mandalorian just keeps
building and luckily it's still on track
for an October release despite other
Hollywood delay is due to coronavirus
and honestly it's just really nice to
have something to look forward to I like
those odds and the latest and I get to
drop in our galaxy's news that tomorrow
Morrison who played Jango Fett in 2002
Star Wars Attack of the Clones will
appear in season two as Boba Fett the
fan favorite bounty hunter who first
appeared in 1980 Star Wars The Empire
Strikes Back and fun fact he's also
voiced both Fett characters in a number
of Star Wars video games so maybe we
need a clone Tamura and while his
appearance was potentially teased in
season 1 when we saw his trademark Spurs
at the end of episode 5 I know you might
be thinking didn't Boba Fett die in
Return of the Jedi when he fell into the
Sarlacc pit I mean we never actually
technically see him die you know
well there's actually a few ways that
this could happen starting with the
possibility that he did in fact survive
the Sarlacc pit like I just said which
was actually the case in the old
expanded universe legend story something
that could be carried over to this Canon
storyline another possibility is that we
continue to learn more about Dinge are
an aka mandos backstory through
flashbacks and boba could appear in one
of those is someone who you know crossed
paths with a young din while he was
being raised by other Mandalorians then
there's some multiplicity angle because
one of the storylines in attack of the
clones revolved around a secret army of
clones that were copies of Jango Fett
and then we learned that Bubba was
actually a clone Jango as well being
raised as his own son so it's definitely
possible that there's some funny cloning
business going on I'm just a simple man
trying to make my way in the universe
now along with Boba Fett returning to
the Star Wars fold we know the animated
favorite ahsoka tano is making her
live-action debut played by rosario
dawson check out our episode breaking
that down if you haven't already plus we
just learned that another popular
animated character bo Catan will be
joining the Mandalorian and will be
played by Katee Sackhoff who also voiced
the character in Clone Wars and rebels
so more on that as we get it and actor
Michael Biehn from Terminator and aliens
Fame will be joining a cast as an
unknown character marking his first
major role in over a decade yeah be
cyborgs don't feel pain I do now when it
comes to directors we also previously
reported that Robert Rodriguez is
joining a circled names for season two
that includes Jon Favreau and Carl
Weathers and we now know that another
accomplished filmmaker ant-man's Peyton
Reed is joining the season as well and
hey you gotta stick with what works so
get ready for another season that feels
like a bunch of mini movies
hey what'd I miss all right friends it's
time for us to kick it over to you now
how do you think Boba Fett is gonna fit
into Mandalorian season to let us know
all your thoughts feelings theories in
the comment section and for more
streaming news or binge guides check out
Rotten Tomatoes calm also do not forget
to join our fan group on Facebook where
you can discuss many things including
what you're watching now like Brian who
just watched better call Saul season 3
you lucky man you and if you don't want
to miss out on any future episodes of
this show be sure to hit that subscribe
button and notification bell and as
always thank you guys so much for
watching the catch up my name is ass
Prez and we hope to see your face in the
next video bye
you